contrairement aux idées reçues on pense
qu'on va prendre du poids en hiver parce
qu'on va manger de la raclette mais en
réalité on était on va changer nos
comportements on va manger on va
grignoter tout on la journée on va faire
des apéros on va consommer de la glace
on va parfois moins pratiquer d'activité
sportive parce qu'il fait trop chaud et
on va prendre du poids donc l'idée c'est
d'essayer non pas de diaboliser certains
aliments mais peut-être de faire les
bons choix ou encore de comprendre à
quel point certains sont très sucrés et
qu'on va peut-être limiter dans le temps
alors qui sont les personnes les plus à
risque j'imagine des personnes
par rapport à quoi par rapport
à ça les personnes les plus à risque que
celles qu'on risque bien entendu de de
perdre cet été voilà qui je dois penser
déjà à remplacer pour la rentrée c'est
un petit peu ma question voilà alors
vous parlez d'alimentation ou de
canicule de chaleur un peu tout
s'accumule quand tu as chaud tu manges
en plus beaucoup de sucre et que tu te
insulter par des vélos
un moment tu passes l'arme à gauche
voilà donc voilà il faut être vigilant
peut-être avec les glaces c'est vrai
qu'il fait chaud on adore les glaces
mais le problème il y en a certains qui
pose certaines glaces peuvent vraiment
problèmes on a tous ce genre de peau
qu'on adore à la maison mais ça c'est
une catastrophe deux raisons la première
c'est que vous le savez c'est sucré vous
avez pas besoin de moi pour ça et vous
savez que dans ce pot de 400 g vous avez
100 g de sucre quand on sait que l'OMS
recommande 25 g de sucre par jour ça
c'est 100 g de sucre ça veut dire que
vous allez avoir une dizaine de morceaux
de sucre juste dans un pot de glace et
ce qui est très très c'est que ils le
mettent sous un conditionnement très
particulier c'est que vous allez le
manger comment à la cuillère et donc
vous allez en manger en blanc
cette transformation contrairement aux
autres glaces qu'on peut avoir sur ce
format là on va prendre une ou deux
boules et on va se dire je prends mes
deux boules je suis très content
tu tu prends comment toi la cuillère ou
plutôt des deux boules moi j'aime bien
sucer les deux boules ça fait plus ça
fait plus de vacances tu Gênes tout le
monde
on a passé une mauvaise journée
22h généralement j'ai pas passé mauvaise
journée
en fin de journée on est fatigué on va
se réconforter dans du sucré et en plus
de ça ils ont toujours des goûts très
particuliers c'est pas uniquement
chocolat
tu as tout un rayon biscuiterie et
mettre le brownie le granola le si tes
colliers le et on cumule trois choses un
peu de sel un peu de gras et un peu de
sucre
qu'on adore et qu'on en mange encore
plus alors en réalité on va prendre
parce que si durant la journée on a fait
attention et on a essayé en ce moment on
se dit je mange une petite salade et
tout ça là et que le soir on gâche tous
nos efforts avec ce pot de crème glacée
ça te nique la journée mais évidemment
vous multipliez ces écarts si vous le
faites une fois dans la saison c'est pas
très grave mais en général on va acheter
un pot puis un deuxième et ça devient
une habitude et notre cerveau va se dire
le soir j'ai envie de ce morceau de
sucre j'ai envie de cette glace et sans
s'en rendre compte à la fin de l'été on
a pris deux ou trois kilos donc l'idée
c'est pas de l'interdire c'est de se
dire je peux me faire plaisir je peux
faire plaisir aux enfants mais je prends
une boule ou deux boules plutôt que de
prendre ce pot et pour les enfants il y
a aussi les glaces à l'eau vous savez
les trucs multicolores très peu sucré
non il y a très bien ça il y a certaines
même sont bio donc en fait il y a pas de
mauvaise sucre donc la glace à l'eau bio
c'est pas mal moi c'est pas mal
de la bonne alternative c'est
problématique le sorbet on va vous dire
que là il y a un sorbet
on se dit on mange des fraises le
problème c'est que dans un sorbet c'est
un peu moins calorique car en fait il y
a pas de matière grasse qu'on va
rajouter dans une glace classique en
revanche il y a plus de sucre donc en
réalité les sorbets sont plus sucrés que
les glaces encore une fois c'est pas
interdit mais prenez conscience que
c'est glace c'est des calories
supplémentaires dont on peut se passer
donc faites-vous plaisir de temps en
temps mais prenez conscience que ça en
réalité c'est un peu des produits
ultra transformés très sucré très gras
et dont on peut se passer et qui vont
peser sur la balance à la fin de l'été
c'est pas une fois c'est pas deux fois
c'est la répétition de ces petits gestes
qui malheureusement bah si on le fait
une fois pendant les vacances pas de
problème le plaisir en réalité il y a
tous ces moments où on veut prendre une
glace on est content mais pas une
habitude et quitte à choisir moi je
préfère une glace classique ou un
esquimau effectivement les glaces à
l'unité on en prend une on a fait
plaisir à tout le monde il y a un
conditionnement et on passe à autre
chose que je kiffe de ouf
je vais t'en parler
je vais en citer plusieurs donc il y a
la glace au chocolat blanc tout chocolat
blanc
[Musique]
et sucrée qu'un cône classique qu'on va
prendre donc si tu connais plaisir c'est
de prendre ça la glace alors
surprise il y a le truc avant
la meilleure
alors peut-être la meilleure le goût
parce qu'à la fin il y a en fait
à la fin tu vois tu es comme c'est comme
vraiment c'est à la fin tu vois vraiment
tu crois que tu as fini et en fait tu as
le petit bout dans le cornet comme ça un
mini cornet et tu manges quoi parce
qu'ils arrivent à vous conditionner pour
que on résume l'expérience de plaisir à
ce petit truc à la exactement donc vous
allez trouver
donc des industriels donc pourquoi pas
une fois de temps en temps mais
comprenez bien que si vous souhaitez
faire attention avec à votre ligne bah
c'est plutôt avec les copains donc pour
les glaces la c'est le mieux
glace à l'eau c'est le mur en réalité
deux trois glaces à l'eau par semaine et
en surveillance qu'on met c'est pas bon
en fait le problème c'est que ils ont
réussi à tout transformer chimiquement
pour qu'en réalité cette glace qui est
quand même sucrée où il y a du sucre il
y a des fruits et bien tout d'un coup on
la trouve fade et donc ça veut dire que
on est peut-être trop habitué au sucre
et qu'en permanence on a des apparences
success trop fort qu'on peut faire très
simplement vous pouvez aussi prendre une
mangue vous la coupez vous la mettez au
congélateur vous mélangez ça avec un
yaourt skir par exemple ou un fromage
blanc et ça vous fait une glace maison
sans sorbetière et ça coûte moins cher
arrête un peu
donne-moi le corps et que je t'ai dit
tout à l'heure
alors il y a un marketing incroyable sur
ce qui est alléger et toutes les études
sont claires dès lors qu'on vous propose
un produit allégé et bien on va en
consommer plus pour en acheter en plus
grande quantité parce qu'on se dit
finalement c'est alléger je peux me
permettre donc moi je pense qu'il faut
une fois pour toute se faire plaisir on
prend un vrai produit en pleine
conscience que c'est sucré plutôt que se
diriger dans ce marketing de la légère
les glaces
[Rires]
pas moi il faut aller sur lui
tu as entendu ce que tu as dit Jimmy
Mohamed il y a un instant
tu fais attention une cuillère par une
cuillère
par contre prépare l'autre pot parce
qu'il va le finir vite
merci merci mon Jimmy Jimmy tu viens
nous dire attention glass mais là c'est
plus dur ce que je lis après sur ma
fiche pendant l'été bannir les boissons
lacs parce que nous quand on boit oh là
là on est persuadé qu'on est les
tauliers tu vois un gars tu fais tu
prends le rouge toi non plus
comment pourquoi alors moi je consomme
jamais ces boissons là j'en prendrai
jamais et j'en donnerai jamais mes
enfants autant alors pour faire très
simple quitte à prendre une boisson
sucrée prenez une vraie boisson gazeuse
sucrée de temps en temps le vrai coca le
vrai Fanta le vrai Orangina passer à
autre chose le problème c'est que c'est
boisson qui contiennent des faux sucres
elles vont contenir ce qu'on appelle des
édulcorants de l'aspartame de lacets
sulfamca rien que les noms vous
comprenez que c'est pas terrible donc
voilà la sus la cest sulfamca ça
s'appelle c'est un édulcorant qui donne
le goût du sucre sans les calories
l'aspartame on connaît tous le problème
c'est que ces édulcorants partagent vous
consommez un Cola avec ces bois ces
trucs light dans le cerveau vous avez un
pic de dopamine parce que vous avez le
goût sucré donc vous êtes très content
le problème c'est que vous n'avez pas le
sucre qui va avec donc en réalité votre
pancréas votre organisme est perturbé et
il va vous faire manger beaucoup plus
donc
pour résumer on dit si tu fais attention
mais tu prends une boisson like moi
parce que moi je prends des boissons pas
et ben très bien passons cet argument ah
oula
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais moi je prends ces boissons ce
concept c'est que c'est édulcorant on
perturbait le microbiote et vont
favoriser du diabète des maladies
cardiovasculaires et l'excès de ces
édulcorants favorise certains cancers en
réalité l'Organisation mondiale de la
santé est très claire ces boissons on
doit les limiter le plus possible
d'autant que on s'habitue au sucre et en
permanence le midi le soir vous avez ce
goût sucré sans le sucre donc on peut
devenir diabétique sans jamais avoir
pris un morceau de sucre en excès mais
un soda zéro une fois de temps en temps
le soir à l'apéro quand même par jour
dans ces Cola vous avez du caramel mais
c'est pas vraiment du caramel c'est un
colorant qu'on appelle le E150d
est-ce que je vous dis c'est écrit noir
sur blanc il y a pas de complot en
réalité ce qui nous vendent bah en fait
c'est écrit il y a pas de piège le E150d
vous regardez au dos c'est du caramel
mais c'est pas vraiment du caramel c'est
du caramel au sulfite d'ammonium c'est
un produit ultra transformé pour créer
ce caramel chimique et bien parfois il y
a des résidus qui vont se créer qu'on
appelle le 4 mi on tenait pas ce nom
quatre amis le Centre international de
lutte contre le cancer le dit que ce
composé intermédiaire peut-être classé
comme cancérigène probable donc en
réalité même si vous passez l'argument
du sucre vous avez le colorant le
mauvais colorant qui est présent dans
d'autres boissons
il vaut mieux boire du normal de temps
en temps faites-vous plaisir prenez un
vrai
paquet de cigarettes
[Rires]
dire que et puis dernier élément dedans
on a de l'acide phosphorique du des
phosphates
en réalité c'est du phosphore c'est ce
qui donne de l'acidité on consommerait
deux à trois fois trop de phosphore dans
notre alimentation et c'est à l'origine
de maladies cardiovasculaires de maladie
rénale et de déminéralisation donc en
réalité ces boissons sucrées qu'on a
normalisées qu'on associe au plaisir en
réalité notamment pour les enfants et
bien nous rendre malade et encore une
fois tout ça c'est écrit noir sur blanc
ça c'est quoi ça je peux te parler
l'hibiscus pourquoi pas une infusion
c'est sans addictus
très peu de sucre là dedans donc une
infusion avec un truc goût fruit et ben
pourquoi pas sans édulcorant sans
calories le problème c'est que ça tu as
une pêche
c'est que ça coûte parfois un peu plus
cher que les collabres
il y a très peu de sucre 3 g de sucre
c'est bien moi de la moitié d'un morceau
de sucre magnifique donc c'est très peu
sucré et bien ça donc ça c'est par là je
bois que ça tu vois l'été
il y a quand même la moitié d'un paquet
dans un collage traditionnel on a 10 g
de sucre pour 100 ml voilà ça veut dire
qu'on a dans une canette on a quasiment
l'équivalent de 4,5 morceaux de sucre
Wally on a la moitié d'un homme
[Musique]
régulièrement c'est l'eau et bien c'est
un peu de l'eau c'est de l'eau avec un
peu de sucre quand même toute la journée
si vous buvez un litre de ce genre de
truc bah la moitié d'un morceau de sucre
pour 100 ml vous le multipliez par 5 6 7
ou 8 ou 10 merde
de temps en temps encore une fois mais
la base de l'hydratation c'est absurde
de vous rappeler ça c'est le bord de
l'eau et de l'eau gazeuse ça passe ça
passeuse
alors ça dépend ce ne sont pas toutes
salées de la même manière et pour une
personne un peu âgée qui n'a pas envie
de boire de l'eau parce qu'il y a pas de
goût et bien une eau un peu pétillante
dans laquelle on peut rajouter je vais
en citer plein comme ça la Rosanna là
c'est bien la Rosanna c'est très bien ça
fait tard santé est un peu plus salée
d'accord
si vous aimez ça pourquoi pas elles ont
toutes un une minéralisation un peu
différente et finalement ça débile plus
ou moins fines mais ça c'est une
histoire de goût en réalité et on peut
aussi le faire quand même exactement
on peut rajouter
moi je préfère ça un peu de sirop en
fond de sirop bien sûr plutôt que c'est
bois
moi je suis pas un bobo comme vous moi
je me finis rosé
[Musique]
donc l'alcool est dangereux pour la
santé
est-ce qu'on peut voir déjà non mais
sans gris est-ce que tu peux voir toi il
met ça quand tu il y a une personne qui
arrive est-ce que déjà c'est pas la
peine de rentrer le ventre
est-ce que tu peux voir déjà
corporellement tu dis lui attention il y
a des on a un problème avec l'alcool en
France il faut dire la vérité quand tu
vois qu'il y a un gros ventre comme ça
tu te dis quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la première c'est que vous allez avoir
une diminution de l'élimination des
graisses deuxièmement vous avez une un
changement dans la répartition des
graisses quand on consomme de l'alcool
et particulièrement de la bière et bien
on va tout prendre dans le ventre et
c'est un peu caricatural donc en réalité
l'alcool c'est très calorique ça fait
prendre du bide et en plus de ça ça
ouvre l'appétit lorsqu'on consomme de
l'alcool en réalité on va manger avec et
quand on prend une boisson alcoolisée
qui va contenir 100 kcal 200 kcal qu'on
en prend deux ou trois on va voir en
très peu de temps 300 ou 400 kcal le
problème c'est que notre cerveau il
comprend pas qu'on a mangé lui pour lui
on a pris simplement de l'eau avec un
peu de sucre donc on va manger encore
plus et c'est comme ça qu'on va alourdir
la balance et qu'on va prendre du poids
à cause de l'alcool sans parler de la
soixantaine de maladies qui est
favorisée par la prise d'alcool et on a
un rapport un peu pathologique avec
l'alcool ça protège de réduire ça donc
lui qu'est-ce qu'il a lui donc lui c'est
quoi si on supprime de notre vie déjà on
va vivre en meilleure santé on va
prendre du poids il boit et ça fait pas
de sport il fait pas de sport et
pourtant il est encore parmi nous
tu es jeune tout va bien mais est-ce que
vous pouvez pas miser sur l'avenir c'est
de se dire ok ça va il y a des plaisirs
éphémères mais est-ce que sur 15 20 ou
30 ans je vais pas le regretter est-ce
que je pourrais pas faire des gestes
simples consommer un peu moins d'alcool
c'est à la portée de tous merci un peu
plus on peut tous le faire bien sûr et
éliminer quand on peut les produits très
transformés honnêtement on peut le faire
pourquoi non pas pour vous punir mais
juste pour miser sur le long terme
expirez vivre le plus longtemps possible
ça la médecine c'est le faire on vit
très longtemps mais en bonne santé sans
incapacité sans médicament et puis pour
plaisir et pour moi
vous avez du diabète on vous donnera un
traitement contre
diabète si on faisait un peu de
prévention et donc en réalité miser sur
l'alimentation l'activité physique c'est
peut-être les premiers des médicaments
qu'on devrait tous il va y avoir plein
de gens qui arrivent
qu'est-ce qui se passe d'alcool par
exemple mais j'ai des camarades qui
boient la vérité Kelly Vedovelli et
Valérie bénaïs je pense qu'elles ont un
très gros problème elle boivent je te le
dis genre 15 canettes de soda par jour
alors si vous avez vu que j'ai
résolution de l'année dernière ça fait
un an que j'ai arrêté le
chantait mieux oui et ben je vois que de
l'eau de base et
en fait
parce que c'est très grave ça c'est la
puissance déjà industriels
mais c'est énorme vendredi matin je les
vois c'est un truc de ouf on dit que le
sucre est aussi addict que de la drogue
que de la cocaïne c'est un peu abusé
mais c'est un peu vrai en réalité et
c'est aussi la puissance des industriels
qui ont normalisé dans les fast food à
la télévision les sponsorings que en
fait en réalité on peut consommer ces
boissons pour du plaisir et au bout d'un
moment notre cerveau il se dit bah oui
j'ai de la dopamine je suis content mais
au bout d'un moment quand on a plus de
sucre on a plus de plaisir et donc on
recommence donc en réalité c'est un
sevrage qu'on doit amorcer et une prise
de conscience encore une fois rien
n'était interdit et souvent on dit mais
c'est pénible avec toi on peut rien
manger bah si bah c'est ce que vous dit
autre femme non mais je peux l'entendre
les gens sont un peu exaspéré mais ça
veut dire à quel point il faut qu'on
revoit les choses de façon différente et
qu'on mise sur des fruits et des légumes
cuisiner un tout petit peu et qu'en fait
mais l'apéro c'est quoi alors non parce
que on va on va parler
trop froid ne pas croire trop froid
malgré la chaleur moi j'aime bien moi je
t'explique moi ce que je fais je joue tu
vois je joue comme ça je fais du sport
mais sous le soleil de ouf alors j'adore
ça moi
il y a des gars qui viennent il faut
savoir
qu'il y a des gars qui sont quand même
on s'asperge on se met de l'eau mais
l'eau très froides en fait elle va vous
rafraîchir très froid mais en fait l'eau
très froide elle va vous rafraîchir mais
au bout de deux ou trois gorgées on a
plus soif on y arrive plus pourquoi
parce que tout d'un coup notre
température corporelle va un tout petit
peu diminuer car on a des récepteurs à
la température dans le tube digestif et
au bout d'un moment en fait et ben on a
plus on a plus soif on sait pas
déshydraté correctement
donc une légèrement fraîche et
préférable à une autre très glacée pour
se réhydrater ça dérange jamais déranger
personne
il fait très chaud tu as envie là j'aime
bien si je prends la bouteille comme ça
et quand les gens me regardent j'aime
bien mettre la bouteille comme ça sur tu
vois alors on peut se laver tel quel ça
permet
en fait elle est un peu douloureuse et
parfois ça fait mal à l'estomac on a mal
au ventre donc buvez-nous un peu fraîche
mais pas trop glacé sinon rapidement ça
coupe la soif
demain tu auras un dentiste tu parleras
vous l'appellerai demain attention aux
apéros
à cause notamment de l'alcool la
charcuterie en réalité
les espèces de trucs alors ce qu'on peut
conseiller c'est que plutôt d'avoir une
assiette dans laquelle on va mettre nos
mains et on va manger en permanence ayez
votre propre portion à moi c'est ce que
je fais moi
alors c'est vrai que c'est pas très
hygiénique effectivement le mec qui met
tes doigts partout
mais non mais il a été faire non mais il
a été faire de la mécanique il arrive le
truc est tout noir c'est dégueulasse
des cuillères celui qui veut il prend
son côté il va là-bas au bout de la
maison je peux l'entendre un paquet
notamment de chips ou de pis on va le
manger de façon compulsive et on va
terminer le paquet il y a toujours des
résidus comme ça il remettent leurs
doigts dedans qui sont satismes et je
déteste ces gens
-là
les doigts gras et remonte les chiffres
les couilles ah c'est horrible toi tu es
sale voilà quand même été comme ça
il faut faire les chips il paraît que
c'est une catastrophe et les chips de
légumes alors souvent on se donne ouais
c'est ça exactement
c'est des produits un peu ultra
transformés qui ont été pris en réalité
donc en réalité vous avez pris quelque
chose qui est bon donc quelque chose un
légume qu'on a mis dans de l'huile et
qu'on a créé de façon artificielle en
réalité dans la nature on n'est pas
censé frire les légumes donc en réalité
mieux vaut manger de temps en temps un
peu de chips que de croire que les chips
aux légumes vont vous permettre de faire
un apéro plutôt sain donc attends
qu'est-ce que tu disais
un autre bail là
on peut pas préparer sa peau au soleil
non très bien
attention le soleil accélère le
vieillissement de la peau donc même si
finalement vous plaire
la peau mais attends oui mais sur le
visage qui est exposé ça accélère le
vieillissement donc en réalité on
devrait protéger pas moi et puis
attention pour les enfants les coups de
soleil dans l'enfance font le lit des
cancers cutanés de l'adulte donc
vraiment si vous avez des enfants la
crème solaire ça coûte un peu cher je
reconnais des fois qui m'a appelé les
enfants faut leur mettre de la crème
solaire j'ai un pote qui m'appelle la
dernière fois il me dit ouais il
s'appelle Richard il dit j'attrape un
coup de soleil un coup de soleil
je dis arrête de me casser les couilles
avec ta chanson
donc même moi je dois mettre de la crème
à la fois pour la protection contre on
peut être maths de peau et aussi avoir
des retentissements du soleil et on peut
aussi avoir un cancer de la peau en
ayant la peau mate donc il faut se
protéger même la crème solaire c'est la
meilleure façon de se protéger à la fois
des cancers c'est un bon mais aussi du
vieillissement cutané en réalité moi les
jeunes ne sont pas sensibles à cet
argument ils ont 15 ans ils ont 20 ans
le cancer ça je l'aurais pas c'est pour
les autres mais quand on leur explique
que leur peau va vieillir beaucoup plus
rapidement et que la crème solaire on
devrait la mettre même en hiver et bien
on va peut-être pour le vieillissement
de la peau je suis d'accord que le
message va passer et je terminerai avec
ça il y a plus de cancer de la peau en
Bretagne que dans le sud de la France
en fait le soleil est caché entre les
nuages exactement se protéger les nuages
n'empêche pas les coups de soleil donc
vraiment le soleil est cachée
vos enfants comment ça le soleil est
caché non
c'est intéressant
et tu dis juste un truc attention au
sport en extérieur oui exactement alors
en ce moment il y a plein de pollen les
gens sont tous malades les allergies
saisonnières les gérer tout son nez qui
coule donc si vous êtes allergique
attention au sport en plein air dehors
parce que vous risquez d'aggraver votre
allergie ah c'est tout bah c'est déjà
pas mal parce que l'allergie lorsqu'elle
n'est pas traitée elle va aller en
s'aggravant et ça peut déclencher des
crises d'asthme et je vois des gens
tousser pensez avoir une bronchite en
plein mois de juin en réalité ils font
une crise d'asthme d'autant que la
qualité de l'air elle est mauvaise donc
quand on associe une qualité de l'air
mauvaise à cause de la pollution plus
les allergènes et bien on augmente les
symptômes de l'allergie donc soyons on
va pas passer les vacances
[Rires]
tu peux pas te manger une glace tu peux
pas te coucher un sauna tu peux pas
demander un soda tu peux pas
tu fermes les volets et tu es dans le
noir rien de faire de les de lesotérisme
c'est hyper important en ce moment on
dort très mal on dort très mal quand ce
qui est en ce moment il fait chaud alors
je vais dire la vérité
j'ai trois personnes qui me font de
l'air
écoute les gars sont hyper sympa il fait
chaud pour deux raisons la première
c'est la chaleur c'est évident on prend
un ventilateur on fait avec les moyens
du bord et la deuxième chose c'est qu'en
fait il fait jour très tard ouais c'est
ça les enfants ils ne comprennent pas
qu'à 20h 21h on leur dise d'aller dormir
parce qu'en fait ils disent mais non
mais il fait jour et en réalité l'heure
d'été perturbe notre horloge biologique
donc le soir on baisse la luminosité en
fermant les volets qu'est-ce que c'est
que cette rassera dis-moi c'est un
vampire j'ai pas pris une glace j'ai pas
pris une boisson
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la lumière du jour en fait elle entraîne
un puissant message d'éveil dans le
cerveau et elle retarde la production de
la mélatonine qui est l'hormone de
mélatonine quand on s'expose au
téléphone portable on va avoir du mal à
dormir mais la lumière jusqu'à 22h23
heures notre cerveau il comprend pas il
pense qu'il faut être actif donc c'est
un conseil pour les parents en réalité
si on a des enfants qui ont du mal à
dormir le soir et bien si possible on
ferme les volets la température va
descendre un petit peu ils vont
peut-être un peu mieux dormir c'est un
conseil vraiment
qui va être les masques là comme ça là
ouais très bien les masques de nuit
effectivement c'est pas mal pour le
soleil
mais c'est pas mal parce que
tu fais Bernard
mais même tu vois
il y a même des petits masques un peu
lesté qui vont appuyer un petit peu sur
le globe oculaire qui peuvent favoriser
le sommeil donc en fait moi je dis
pourquoi pas si ça vous aide à mieux
dormir je préfère ça que des somnifères
avec la télé dans ces cas-là continuer
tel quel donc c'est pas il y a pas de
règle aucun problème si vous êtes bien
mais moi je m'adresse à ceux par exemple
tu vas voir un problème du sommeil qui
vont se dire bah tiens effectivement je
sais pas quoi faire et ben c'est un
conseil simple qui coûte pas d'argents
[Rires]
toujours pas rentré
au restaurant ouvert jusqu'à 6h du matin
c'est bon quoi non mais je sais bah oui
je comprends vision avec des troubles du
sommeil en fait quand on se réveille de
façon très précoce le matin c'est rien
mais ça peut s'intégrer parfois dans une
dépression et on peut avoir des
symptômes dépressifs qu'on va mettre de
côté qui peuvent être révélés par un
trouble du sommeil donc si jamais vous
avez des réveils nocturnes très précoce
vous faites des cauchemars vous avez un
sommeil de mauvaise qualité et vous
dites je bois un peu du noir en ce
moment je vous invite à en parler à
votre médecin traitant on discuter
peut-être qu'il y a rien et c'est
justement mais peut-être que vous avez
besoin d'être aidé en fait
c'est le début
il a terminé sa glace
merci
merci Jimmy merci Jimmy merci Jimmy
merci mon Jimmy Jimmy tu reviens nous
voir quand tu veux on a besoin de
conseils je te jure que tu nous as tu
nous as fait frétiller